deep in the forests of Sumatra a strange
organism survives by sucking the life
from a toast
in this hot dark and damp environment
filled with tigers leopards rhinos and
bears the Flora can be nearly as Eerie
as the fauna
when British colonists first encountered
the plant in 1818 they could hardly
believe what they were seeing and
smelling
Dr Joseph Arnold later wrote had I been
alone and had there been no Witnesses I
should I think have been fearful of
mentioning the potent smell or extreme
dimensions of this flower so much does
it exceed every flower I have ever seen
or heard of a swarm of flies hovered
over its blood red flesh huge petals
stinking of precisely the smell of
Tainted beef what they had found was no
ordinary flower
it was the Rafflesia plant its flower
measuring almost one meter across with a
putrid smell of rotten cheese sweat
garlic and decomposing meat
it's a plant with no stem no roots and
no leaves a plant that exists as a
parasite to its unsuspecting host
the plants in the reflegia genus are
some of the strangest in the world and
among the rarest
they grow in rainforests from Thailand
and Malaysia to Indonesia and the
Philippines and are almost impossible to
reproduce in Laboratories despite their
smell Rafflesia are so iconic that
they're one of the national flowers of
Indonesia they appear on stamps and
currency in Malaysia their buds are
considered a delicacy in Thailand and
the indigenous people of Borneo use them
for medicinal purposes
while other smelly flowers like the
Titan arum draw huge crowds whenever
they bloom in Botanic Gardens Rafflesia
flowers have rarely been seen outside of
their jungle habitat
that makes them exceedingly mysterious
and perhaps Stranger than other corpse
flowers
even though Rafflesia flowers haven't
been turned into tourist attractions
like the Titan arum they share some
important traits with the other pungent
plant
both are enormous Rafflesia being the
largest flower known to humans and Titan
arum being the largest inflorescence
which is a collection of many small
flowers
and both smell absolutely terrible
but why on Earth would something evolve
to be this stinky and why are the
biggest flowers in the world also the
stinkiest
[Music]
the most obvious traits of Rafflesia are
its enormous size and its potent smell
the smallest of the species have flowers
the size of dinner plates which is
already quite large if you're used to
seeing roses or daisies in your garden
and the largest so far was almost one
meter in diameter which is about the
height of a seven-year-old child
but the more scientists have learned
about the plant The Stranger it's become
Rafflesia plants are Hollow parasites
meaning they can't survive at all
without feeding off another plant
and their host of choice are viny lyanna
plants in the same family as grapes
the Rafflesia infiltrates its host with
a single file line of cells that can
stretch for more than 10 meters sucking
moisture and nutrients from the Vine
depending on the species these threads
will spread through the vine for up to
18 months before a bud ever appears
from there it might be another nine
months before the bud blooms into an
enormous flower and the flower only
lasts four to five days before
shriveling up
to try and understand more about the
mysterious reflegia over the past 10
years scientists have been digging into
its genome and what they found has been
as incredible as everything else about
the plant
first researchers discovered that
Rafflesia abandoned its ability to
photosynthesize millions of years ago
it has no chloroplast genome which means
it doesn't have any of the cells
necessary for photosynthesis
then perhaps even more astonishing is
that Rafflesia has engaged in horizontal
Gene transfer
this is when genetic information is
exchanged between organisms without
reproduction
for a long time this was thought to be
possible only among bacteria and
single-celled prokaryotes
an example is antibiotic resistant
bacteria humans often feed cattle and
other livestock antibiotics to prevent
infections the bacteria in those animals
evolve to become resistant to those
antibiotics and in some cases the
bacterial changes have then transferred
into strains of bacteria that infect
humans like staphylococcus aureus
but in Rafflesia horizontal Gene
transfer has happened between it and its
hosts multiple times throughout its
evolutionary history
it owes two to three percent of its
nuclear genome to the host plant and as
much as 50 of its mitochondrial genome
to The Host
and because there's genetic information
from Plants besides tetrasstigma which
is what Rafflesia uses as a host today
researchers think Rafflesia DNA might
hold a record of its previous hosts
the host parasite Arrangement dates all
the way back to the mid Cretaceous about
a hundred million years ago but with so
many other genetic strategies why did
Rafflesia also become so smelly and so
unpleasant
before we get into the wise and hows of
Rafflesia consider what lies on the
forest floor
not just leaves and dirt but all the
things that are constantly in some
process of decay
dead wood and plant material feces from
all manner of animals and decomposing
animals from Tiny Birds to huge
ungulates like deer
over time a diverse range of insects has
evolved to live on this rotting material
and Rafflesia is capitalizing on these
insects in a very unusual way
many flowering plants rely on insects
that search for sweet nectar and
enticing smells this is often a mutually
beneficial relationship in which both
plants and insects benefit from coming
in contact
the plant gets pollinated and the insect
gets nectar
but plants that evolved for carry-on
mimicry are in a far more one-sided
relationship
insects that normally lay their eggs in
feces or rotting meat come to the
carry-on plants to do just that they get
covered in pollen while depositing their
eggs but when the eggs hatch the larvae
have nothing to eat
the Flies do most of the work and the
plants get all the benefit
this is exactly how Rafflesia operates
it emits chemical compounds like
dimethyl disulfide and dimethyl
trisulfide
those are both compounds produced by the
bacterial breakdown of meat which
explains why the flower smells so
terrible
but when scientists compared blowflies
visiting rotten meat versus Rafflesia
flowers in the wild one species of fly
made up 97 of all the visitors to the
flower while this same species accounted
for only 25 percent of the Flies
visiting the rotten meat
scientists found that riflesia was also
producing other chemicals like
benzonoids for that reason the
scientists hypothesized that Rafflesia
uses more than just the smelliest smells
to attract specific flies it has its own
unique chemical mix
but Rafflesia doesn't stop there the
spongy texture of the petals also mimics
decaying flesh and some species of the
plant even generate heat a trick called
thermogenesis
it's rare in Plants but other stinky
species do it as well such as the skunk
cabbage for athleisure the heat might
help disperse its stink more widely
luring in carry-on flies could also be
why such smelly plants have evolved to
be so huge
their greater size might make them look
more like dead animal carcasses might
help flies see them on the crowded
forest floor and could help to
temporarily trap the insects because
while carry-on plants like Rafflesia
don't eat flies like carnivorous plants
they still need the Flies to get up
close and personal with them
[Music]
unlike many other flowers whose pollen
is light and powdery the male Rafflesia
flowers have a viscous liquid pollen
because of that the carry-on fly who
visits it needs to come in very close
contact with the flower in order to be
coated with the sticky wet substance
once the pollen dries it can remain
viable for several days to weeks as the
fly darts around the forest
if it comes in contact with a female
rafflegia flower the pollen is
rehydrated by the moisture of the plant
and the female flower is pollinated
from there it produces fruit that looks
like a pat of manure and Carries
hundreds of thousands of tiny seeds no
larger than a grain of sawdust
how those seeds go on to become
parasites in new Vines is still a
mystery do ants bury them near the roots
of leonovines
or maybe small mammals carry the seeds
up to the vines
to this day scientists have not figured
it out
the only botanist who has ever
successfully cultivated Rafflesia in a
garden has never successfully germinated
one from Wild seeds instead she grafts
tissues from a Rafflesia infected Vine
into another host plant
over the years she's raised 16 flowers
from Bud to bloom but so far the male
and female flowers haven't bloomed at
the same time so pollination has never
yet occurred
that means you're unlikely to see a
Rafflesia flower anytime soon unless you
travel out to the Jungle
though if you're interested in other
smelly plants there are plenty of
gardens that successfully raise Titan
arum flowers
there's still so much we don't know
about Rafflesia a recent chemical
analysis of one species found that it
might also have strong antibacterial
properties for antibiotic resistant
bacteria
and it's even possible there are new
species in the Rafflesia genus that have
yet to be discovered
but unfortunately Rafflesia don't grow
in very abundant numbers and that makes
them especially vulnerable to Forest
fragmentation and habitat destruction
for now though they'll keep growing in
the dark and The Damp luring in Curious
humans and eager flies with their
absolutely terrible stench sometimes
when making these videos I end up
Googling some questionable things
we've all been there wondering if your
FBI agent is taking note of your
internet activity
you can go Incognito but that isn't
enough to keep your searches truly
private the only way to browse the
internet without leaving a trace is to
use a VPN and the best one to use is
nordvpn
nordvpn is based away from the EU and
U.S jurisdictions and has no obligation
to collect your personal information
they don't record monitor store log or
share anything you do
they can't provide any details about
your internet activity to anyone ever
why because they don't have anything to
provide
but it's not just about questionable
Google searches the internet is becoming
an increasingly restricted place
geoblocking in its mildest form stops
you from watching certain Netflix shows
and at its worst allows tyrannical
governments to prevent people from using
Google or access the news everyone
deserves an open internet and nordvpn is
helping to make that a reality with a
simple click of a button you can change
what country you're browsing the
internet from you can access the
libraries of streaming services in other
countries access blocked websites and
browse totally privately it's a simple
streamlined super effective service that
I rely on all the time
so go to nordvpn.com real science to get
nordvpn's Cyber Security package and
four months free it's risk-free with
nord's 30-day money-back guarantee and
if you're looking for something else to
watch right now you should watch our
latest video about the insane biology of
the seahorse or watch real engineering's
latest video about the insane
engineering of the Spitfire
[Music]